[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ "Stranger Things"
theme plays ]
-Hey, guys.
We're the cast
of "Stranger Things."
And we're here at
Madame Tussauds wax museum
in Times Square.
And we're gonna surprise some
fans who think they're here
to see a new
"Stranger Things" wax exhibit.
-Yeah, we're just
waiting on Jimmy.
-Coming! Coming!
Hi. I'm here.
I'm Barb from Season 1.
-Yeah, we get it.
-We know.
-We realize.
-Let's surprise people!
[ All cheering ]
-Everyone get in the zone.
Get in the Zen.
-No laughing.
-Yep.
-All right, shh.
♪♪
-This is our photographer.
You can sit on the bench and
then you can look at -- Yeah.
Come sit.
-Oh, great.
-All right,
now you can take a photo
if you look
right in this lens here.
Okay. And 3, 2, 1...
-[ Screams ]
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-How you doing?
-Oh!
-Jimmy Fallon. I'm Barb. Hi.
[ Laughs ]
-Great.
-Okay, great. Okay?
3, 2, 1...
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Can I just sit down?
-Oh [bleep]
-Oh, my God!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Laughter ]
-Big smiles. And 3, 2, 1...
-Can I get a tissue?
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Laughter ]
-Look at this shirt.
That is what I'm talking about.
"Justice for Barb."
-All right.
-3, 2, 1...
-Hey, guys.
-Whoa!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Laughter ]
-Are you guys --
-We like four.
-Come see Barb.
-Barb. Look, look.
-Hey, Barb.
-Oh, hi. I'm Jimmy Fallon.
Nice to...
[ Laughter ]
Hello. I'm Barb.
-Oh!
-We look so stupid.
[ Laughter ]
You scared the crap out of me.
"Oh, man! Don't do that."
-[ Laughs ]
Can we get him
a change of pants?
-Okay, take a look back like
you're scared of the Demogorgon.
Like, look back at that.
-Aaaaah!
[ Laughter ]
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Oh, my God!
-Okay. In 3, 2, 1...
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
And 3, 2, 1...
[ All scream ]
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Oh, my God!
-Hi. How you doing?
-Oh! Don't cry.
Everybody in. Squeeze!
-1, 2, 3...
-Hey!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]